these will be the 95th Academy Awards
and the critics favorite for best
picture is everything everywhere all at
once
nominated in 11 categories the genre
jumping film about navigating familial
drama and the Multiverse features a
majority Asian cast
I've never been this many Asian actor
nominees if Michelle yo wins cheat for
leading actress she would be only the
second woman of color to ever win in the
category
no black actors were nominated in the
leading
the nominated for best director that's
renewed criticism of the Oscars lack of
diversity we saw a couple of great great
performances and directors that got
overlooked
also up for Best Picture are the
Blockbuster sequels Avatar the way of
water and top gun Maverick
but it's the German war film All Quiet
on the Western Front that critics say
may deliver a surprise win
comedian Jimmy Kimmel will host for the
third time expect jokes about last
year's slap with a capital S when actor
Will Smith attacked host Chris Rock over
a comment about Smith's wife the show's
producers were criticized for allowing
Smith to stay until the end this year a
crisis team is reportedly ready for
anything and Smith is banned from
attending also missing will be Ukraine's
President Vladimir zielinski whose
reported request to make a virtual
address as he did at the Berlin Film
Festival last month was declined by
Oscar's organizers the evening's intent
is to focus solely on Hollywood's
achievements what we're honoring is
these people who are at the top of their
game they've produced art for us that's
very important and that makes a
difference in the world this year's
Oscars will be a test of whether the
show has truly rebound from the pandemic
following two years of the lowest
ratings ever and unlike last year all 23
categories will be presented live which
will make for another long show and a
test of the viewing Public's endurance
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Los Angeles